in four days time our daughter's gonna
marry a guy she just met ooh Bali
millions of miles from home I just
really want to kiss you
look like I looked up for the first time
and realized everything I ever wanted
was right in front of me
I was throwing a career away just like
her mother did so I'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen to him
champagne I feel like
you're gonna be my friend and you guys
have this epic friendship you've been in
so many movies together I wanted to know
when was the moment you knew that you
were going to be friends for life when
we met a week ago
yeah when we met
why would I'm serious you make the joke
and then you're serious when I make the
joke well that's we got to change all of
that because we have to be better we
have to be better people giving
interviews yes okay so let's give an
honest answer oh it's last week
when we met yeah well
there was just an ease and a comfort and
we just
I don't know it's we're both from the
south there was a lot of booze there too
you know
after you've you know after you've
thrown up on each other you have to be
friends
isn't that kind of how it works once
you've all right and then you're like
all right I'll be your friend
okay one lesson speaking of throwing up
here's here's my favorite thing George
did in the whole movie you didn't ask me
what it was but I'm going to tell you
you know what I'm gonna say no when we
were doing the dancing scene and at one
point I'm having to chug a glass of
liquor and I'm
supposed to be so drunk that like I can
hardly choke it down and he's holding my
hair back he just grabbed my hair and
he's holding it back while I'm trying to
drink this thing and it was my favorite
thing it was just so I thought that's a
real that's a real friend it's so funny
because when I saw that I was like I
wonder if that's ever happened to them
in real life like not on never never
he's never held my hair back but never
I've never been drunk really you
um Julia your character Georgia has
David saved on her phone is something
really funny in the movie and it made me
wonder what you have George saved in
your phone under well schmuck
Batman
lowercase letters
that hurts
you should see yeah
I know you're cooking up something
really mean Julia I can feel it I can
feel it
no I'm not going to say it I'll be nice
I have it under Jay cell no just back
hair and then
lowercase lowercase the lowercase is the
worst I brought up Batman though because
George with Keaton returning I'm a major
fan would you ever would you ever give
it another go well I think that I did so
well uh in the first one that I think I
don't think I can top the work that I
did with uh you know lines like freeze
freeze you know oh because it's two two
freezes I was cold just you doing that I
wasn't ready no we tried it because it's
two words but it's the same word freeze
freeze and I have with different
meanings yeah two different means so I
go freeze freeze
I am freezing right now yeah yeah you're
like Arnold Schwarzenegger in the movie
right now yeah that's my favorite Batman
movie by the way and I think you are the
best well then you actually have an
issue no I'm just a 90s kid I'm just a
90s kid
um you guys have also done so many cool
genres together Heist Thriller rom-com
is there a genre you would want to
tackle together that you haven't done
yet Musical yeah Opera
or a nature documentary yes that's a
that's a genre
I'll hover in the Land Rover while my
partner Jim wrestles The live alligator
um yes let's do a a a a musical animal
thing let's do a African musical sure
Opera sure yeah good or like an Italian
David Attenborough Out of Africa Arya
yes that'll play well out of Arya
adavaria you're so proud of Arya mines
I'm out of Arya time
we had to joined our club I love it I
could do this all day you guys are
absolutely fantastic your chemistry's so
effortless I wish I could put it in a
bottle and take it with me on dates you
can actually yeah he's selling it we'll
be selling it at the concession of the
movie we'll be there in the back yeah
this is good day
good day
hey you've learned that to make me look
bad you don't need my help there uh you
guys are so funny in this movie oh I at
first just had to ask you about the beer
pong scene yeah because it was so good
yeah tell me about shooting that like
who had the best shot and what was it
like playing that game with George and
Julia well first of all George is really
good at it I never missed a shot so that
was never yeah for like the the you know
well really like you've been practicing
oh my God he's so good at it I also have
never I actually just for the first time
after the movie but at the time when we
shot it I had never played beer pong
before in my life oh wow and then when I
actually just recently did it I think
maybe I was taking some pointers from
George and I it was actually really good
and they were kind of like shocked
because I was like I've never played
before but then I actually did really
well
um but no and also everybody thinks that
like we were actually drinking during
that scene which is not the case at all
um especially George and Julia they
really seemed like they were intoxicated
and they were not it was all just what
water we just saw that first take first
scene and we're just like oh my God this
is brilliant this is yeah yeah we were
in awe of what they were doing because
we weren't expecting it that that whole
bit was supposed to be choreographed or
I think that was originally the plan but
then they were like no we've got this
and we're like oh what does that mean
and then and then they did that they're
gonna go see the movies like basically
all one take they just had like two
cameras and they just went for it and
were catching all of those moments and
it was genius it really was it came off
so far people loved it I think when we
yeah when we when we premiered in London
people clapped
oh my God yeah when I was watching it
last night like everyone was just
laughing so hard it just took you back
that's why I wanted to first ask you
guys about that but obvi like was it
just a dream to work with them and what
I guess what advice would you have to um
a young actor going into a movie with
George and Julia oh interesting that's a
good question you you know I feel like
I've always been you know I've worked
with a lot of can I ask you this
question when I get it yeah
I mean I think there's really no set
formula obviously but I think that when
you're I mean I've haven't such I've had
such an amazing opportunity to work with
such brilliant actors that I look up to
so much and it's really nerve-wracking
when you feel like you're the like
you're the kid on set and you don't want
to bother them at all but I think just
like my advice would be just to not be
afraid of that and to just like go for
it because it will affect the
performance and the outcome of of the
movie and the scene so
um and it really helps when they are
just so welcoming and nice and sweet and
Julia immediately felt like a she has
such a motherly and comforting energy
that was instant and she made me feel so
at ease I really look up to her in so
many ways and George again is like such
a good time to be around I mean
literally everybody loves someone said
he's helping move cables and lift things
and constantly just like active always
like the man doesn't sit down yeah he
doesn't when are you tired
I'm always on it's so funny I love um
what you just said about Julia because
there's a moment towards the end of the
film where Caitlyn you have a scene with
Julia and it's just you too and it's a
little emotional and I remember watching
it and I was thinking I wonder what
Caitlyn's thinking right now and and is
she observing or learning anything from
her in this moment and so I wanted to
ask you about that scene she is so
um especially with the words that she
says to to Lily are so like profound and
the way that she says it I just felt
like like there was like I couldn't do
anything else but believe exactly what
she was saying and she's so good at what
she does and she really just lets the
dialogue be what it is and she's so
natural and grounding in every way
possible
um that scene was really cool just
because I don't know one-on-one with
Julia in a movie
in that kind of scene where it's you
know
two characters basically apologizing to
each other and there's so much love
there and
I love her so much and it just felt like
it was the really just the best day
making that scene come to life oh I love
hearing that Maxim I wanted to ask you
the same about George because you have
so many great solo scenes of them and
then do you carry him at one point in
the film do I remember that I was like
do I remember this correctly so I need
to hear about that so we were we were
planning
I'll pick him up any day so we were we
were supposed to pick up all together
but it was so complicated I don't know
how we're gonna do that like out of the
water and stuff and we had the camera
fooling us so I said George how about if
we just uh like uh how about if I just
pick you up ah good idea
I was just like okay five hours later I
was still picking you up
it was it was awesome did you learn
anything from your time with him like by
just observing him and the scenes you
guys had together I mean I I've observed
a lot I guess and I've seen his movie uh
even before so you know no like finding
out that he was actually the the person
that like I've always known you know
like through whatever interview
something was just like oh my God person
you know he's really got a full-on he
loves his job it was funny my producer
um was telling me that you both were in
a movie called One Fine Day a separate
movie so I just thought that was like
yeah it was an extremely bad guy though
so funny yeah yeah well it's nice to see
you like in this rom-com and in this
space both of you guys were so good and
the relationship was so fun
um Caitlyn you were mentioning earlier
about working with these like huge
actors and obviously you know you worked
with Keaton and dope sick and now
Clooney and took it to paradise and I'm
just such a big Batman fan you've worked
with two Batman so I need to know do you
feel the bat signal calling you would
you ever want to be in a bathroom no I'm
not even having shoes between a Batman
which I cannot do no I am not cruel
George asked me and I'm like George no I
can't I love you both so much I really
can't wait George Clooney asked you he's
like he asked me every day I'm like I'm
not not doing it not doing this with you
so I'm not gonna do it
um it's hilarious but uh yes I would
love are you talking like the Batman
world they're just like yes I would
that's like
a thing that I haven't done yet and
really wanting to do I've always wanted
to be in like a superhero type role like
kind of dream job love it yeah I'd love
to be a Batman yeah yeah
of course you know I mean it's always
been
uh it's always been a dream of mine you
know since I was a kid I mean I've
always watched superhero movies you know
of course one day I would love to pop
supports everything I do that's because
everything she does is perfect he's
exaggerating are you I'm really not
Lucas I am so excited for you because I
know you've been working for like 10
years now yes and the fact that your
face is on a big screen twice in the
last three months I mean like that just
must be so insane for you
it it is yes I'm I'm uh I'm just I'm
just very humbled by the the responses
that I get and
to be lucky enough to you know uh
be in such inspiring stories and Men
provide entertainment and escapism it's
it's uh
it's it's hard to it's hard to measure
yeah I'm just I'm just trying to stay
focused on the fact that it's supposed
to be fun and I I want to be able to
capture all the essence of it yeah well
you did and it's funny I hope you had
fun doing it because it's so much fun
watching you in this your paw is so
clumsy and I was reading that you said
that the physicality was a little it was
a little bit of an uncomfortable
challenge for you and I was wondering
he's so amazingly clumsy and hilarious
what did you look to did you look to
anything to sort of find that or did you
watch anything that inspired you I work
with the I work with colors and animals
um wow so basically I found it when
you're looking for a physicality it's
always interesting
to find what animal this character would
be in life you know
and uh
so for this one I I I I went with a I
went with a slot
which I paired with a hamster
and it's I know it's very weird I don't
even know why I'm sharing this process
but what do you mean this is amazing
sometimes if you're gonna play a black
predatorial bad guy you know you're
gonna go baby for a wolf and You observe
the physicality and you it kind of gives
you something and for this one it was
very like it's it's all about love and
so confident and happy that for me the
slot with this you know Applause and
always wanted to hug you and hug a tree
so that this was for the love and and
the hamster was like this kind of thick
you know on the wheel like spinning off
the wheel like bumping into a thing so I
kind of made that soup and um and and it
was Spotlight it just it just came
exactly the way I so funny you say that
because now it's like I literally
pictured all those movements did you
watch videos of because I've seen sloths
in Costa Rica amazing literally to not
exert energy like move that slowly
yeah I watched a lot of videos I mean I
didn't spend I wasn't portraying a
hamster or a sloth so I didn't go that
deep but
um it's giving sloth
you know that moment where it's like
surprise and he's like oh you know all
that little hand gesture that it's all
like upstairs I also wanted to ask you
you about the kiss you have with Julia
because it's so it's it's like iconic
cringe and so amazing cut it cringe what
was it like shooting that that's that's
a cool uh Association iconic cringe
that should be that this should be my
biography name iconic cringe by Lucas
Bravo I would read it yes yeah it's a
two-page biography
one page is about slots
two pages signed by George Clooney
and you have to take a casamigo shop
before what was it like shooting that
scene
um
wait which you know we're talking about
the kids oh yes
um
well it's it's just a kiss you know at
the end of the day it's yeah you have to
forget about the fact that you know
every single movie Julia's been in that
you're a fan that she's the most
beautiful woman in the world the most
talented and when she smiles butterflies
are flying and Rainbows are shooting in
the sky so you put all your life
yourself aside and you become Paul so I
was with my sloth and my hamster and I
was like okay kissing sin I love this
person so much I wanna
uh yeah it's you know we're
professionals at the end of the day we
cannot we cannot be distracted by our
uh fanaticism yeah like being a fan of
someone yeah absolutely what about with
George because well with George wickest
we we kissed with we I was a fan and
everybody was just yeah I I couldn't
hold it you couldn't hold it then two
twice six years men alive like I
couldn't I had to yeah I know two times
sexy it's wild I was reading that Julia
Roberts really wanted someone cast as
Paul that would really piss off George
Clooney you saw your tape she was like
there he is that is so funny so what was
it like being able to play a character
that gets under George Clooney's skin
and did you have any fun moments with
him on set
it's it's it's
I get that a lot but at the same time we
we at such a beautiful relationship with
Georgia it's hard to imagine that that
could ever get under his skin
uh because it just took me under his
wing and helped helped me navigate this
entire Journey gave me such great advice
and just made me made this entire
experience uh a dream you know we
laughed we played we we
drank we everything was just uh
everything was a good memory it's always
good news you know did you ask him about
that we talked about it we talked about
it and I was like you know George you
need you need to be
don't be so hard on your Batman he I
actually loved it as a kid I loved it he
didn't believe me and I was like I'm a
90s kid yeah me too yeah I was
I love the eyes and the surfing on the
dinosaur and he he wouldn't believe that
I was actually not being sarcastic it's
a reference in my childhood and and
um
so yeah
um one day one day you'll believe me I'm
still working on that
um well I'm so excited for people to see
in this
you are also going to be in another
rom-com called the honeymoon and I was
thinking about how the honeymoons in
Italy and ticket to Paradise is in Bali
and Miss Harris goes to Paris and Emily
in Paris is in Paris and so I was
wondering for your next project where do
you hope
that that project or that film or plot
takes place I would love to shoot
something in Japan
be amazing they would be like oof I
could end my career like okay thank you
good I I just the idea of being you know
in a location for the the for three
months like it's it's perfect because
you really have time to you know dive in
and know the place and uh I would love
to shoot a movie in Japan is there a
genre that you that you love to explore
that's not like in the romantic comedy
I love everything as long as the story
as a meaning I think it I love
um uh and from kind of informational
movies uh you know like Mark Ruffalo
does you know Spotlight dark Waters
movies
based on a true story and that you know
gives a message that everybody should
hear and um
I don't know add a little gravitas to my
to my uh range
I love that well I can't wait to see you
in a future informational film what
advice again I can't leave without audio
about what advice do you have
um for someone trying to get along with
their exes with their partner's EX
um I don't know I'm I'm in good term
With All My Exes so I'm not a great
advice for that I think you should
always uh you should always leave a
story
before
um before the sourness kicks in you know
when you're still friends and there's
still love and it's hard to to do
because as a normal human being you want
to
um Salvage that love you want to save it
from burning but there's a moment where
you have to sacrifice that the last bits
of love that you have and leave if you
want to stay friends for a long time
um which I always
which I'm able to do for some reason
so just just leave when it's still still
time there you go it's not for the faint
of heart this is not his first rodeo
okay let's go let's go here we go which
one there's only one I see two oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no Dad please stop doing that
oh my God
I'm praying for an asteroid oh as a
hopeful romantic I just want to thank
you for bringing this romantic comedy
hopeful romantic screen hopeful romantic
yes you never heard that time how's that
going for you absolutely fabulous
fantastic yes we're still waiting on my
meet cute okay but um I love rom-com so
much obviously as do many people and I
wanted to know why do you why do you
think people love them and why do you
think we need them I think we need them
now because these are dark and desperate
times I think and so anything that
brings also I think consciously with it
we did have the chance for this movie to
sell it to streamers and to you know
they have to go straight to smaller
rooms and smaller screens and and it was
very important to us to make a movie to
laugh to try and get a lot of people in
a room laughing together do you know
what I mean because that's something
we've all missed desperately over the
last three years so um yeah I think it's
incredibly needed these are difficult
times and so anything that can provide I
started writing it with my friend Dan at
the beginning of the pandemic and just
the writing of it was an antidote to the
smallness and difficulty and darkness
and fear that we were all living through
and so just to be writing something in
Sunny climbs with funny people was
amazing so then to get to make it was
ridiculous it's so surreal how are you
feeling now having just explained that
and here we are and it's not out yet the
world hasn't seen it so how are you
feeling like right now I feel I mean
it's been lovely so far it's been really
nice we had to Premiere in London a
couple of weeks ago and that was great
and so yeah proud and you know anxious
obviously but um you know but yeah I
mean thrilled I'm grateful yeah but I
mean you're such a veteran you know you
have done like the Mamma Mia movie you
know here we go again Mamma Mia The Best
Exotic Marigold Hotel what would you say
are like the key ingredients to a
successful rom-com in this modern era
because seeing George and Julia I'm I
was born in the 90s yeah so it there is
some Nostalgia there yeah but for the
modern era what are those key successful
you got a cat I think you gotta care you
could in the end you can be funny you
know it's yeah not to forget the wrong
basically in the calm like you've got to
care and I think maybe where the genre
started to fail is that you stopped
caring and it started to be more about
set pieces and alerts from set pieces at
peace and the cliches became a bit more
obvious the airport dash of the public
declaration so let's be kind of overused
you know what I mean or you feel like
you've seen them and you stopped caring
and so the great thing about working
with these guys apart from the fact that
they're Geniuses and gorgeous and all
that stuff is the kind of shared history
that they bring with them and just how
much people want to believe in their
friendship and want to see them hook up
do you know I mean maybe not literally
but you know we've had the screen the
other night and they there's a kiss in
the movie and there was just Applause in
the cinema which I've rarely hurt
because that's how much people want them
to be together so in the end that you
have to care that's would be my main
ingredient yeah it's so true because I
also read that you said you know you
could have the best script ever in the
most amazing backdrop but sometimes it
lands on the chemistry of the two leads
did I say that yeah I read that you said
that thank you very much for reading me
no yeah not that I'm arguing that this
is either of those things but um yeah
you've gotta that's that's the bird in
the end it's like all the fuss behind
the camera doesn't matter what's on
screen and you've got to wonder in the
end you need to want to see the two of
them hook up you know in whatever form
yeah yeah that's what you need and so if
you have that and George and Julia bring
that with them which is a gift for me it
makes much better than it's and you're
giving that gift you're sharing
everything thank you because I I was
also reading that you read this I'm
sorry you wrote this script with both of
them as the leads yeah in the very first
conversation so I was wondering was
there film that they did together and
was there like a scene that they had
together previously that was in um
Brilliance the Ted Griffin or Oceans 11
and talk I think but it's a brilliant
scene where she's like she says you're
allowing a thief and he says I never
lied about being a thief which is I
think probably the best two lines I've
ever written
um and then he says does he make you
laugh about Andy Garcia and she goes he
doesn't make me cry which is also a
brilliant bit of writing so um but it's
also just their shared friendship on and
off screen and off screen as well do you
know the the history of them do you know
what I mean but so the way they play
together uh you know it's just it was
just brilliant for me and they really do
their friendship's real and genuine and
will last forever so it's a beautiful
thing yeah and I actually you went
downstairs and I actually went into the
room to talk to them right after you and
you could just feel their friendship I
was telling them that I wish that I
could bottle up their chemistry and take
it with me on dates and they were joking
and they were like yeah you could buy it
in the gift shop after it would be nice
I'd buy some I
we do the same and then I go okay we're
just going to relay it will be 20
minutes and normally actors will go back
to their trailers and do the thing and
they would just stay there and we would
like around them and they'd be laughing
together in the middle and then you'd be
like okay ready and they go okay cool
and then they carry on it so it's just
it's warm and it's real and their
families love each other and uh Danny
Julius husband was there and uh I'm
always there with the kids and so and
Juliet you know popped around you know
she's like a godmother to both the kids
and you know it's lovely I mean nothing
but a gift for me and to hang out with
them is a you know pure joy what's been
so fun did you learn anything from
having done you know other sort of
rom-coms by watching George Clooney and
Julia Roberts yeah I mean she's the
she's the queen she's the queen and when
she says she has she's very they're both
very good at taking stuff away I don't
need that I don't need that I can do
that with the look you know they're
amazingly good at knowing what's right
and what and tell me what's right so um
yeah every day it was a school day for
me yeah are one thing in particular that
you could share with us that you were
like wow that's interesting I've never
picked up on that yeah actually I mean
the thing the younger actors took from
there is their work ethic it's how hard
they work there's them radio mined and
so I have cancer and there's one day we
did it's really hot day and by the end
of the day both Billy and Caitlin would
admit that they were slightly flagging
and I could hear George and Julia going
and we still got it and we still got it
because every tank they're just bang on
they know everyone else's loans they
know where the camera is you know
they're just and it's not just
experience it's commitments as well and
they'd have fun and they do have fun
they love what they do but they work
really hard and that's obviously another
gift for me it's so good
um you mentioned the younger actors
Caitlyn is just she's so incredible did
you see her in anything previously
something else that didn't work out and
so she was my friend and then I bumped
into her a bit before it and said I've
written something for you I'm going to
send it to you and normally that's a
really Naf chat outline you know what I
mean which is incredibly not what it was
and she's like yeah sure great and I
already have so um yeah it was the
easiest city in the world and then
George and Julia were both huge fans of
her so I think I told them not I didn't
ask their permission but I said I'm
gonna offer Lily to Caitlyn Diva and
they're both oh amazing so um yeah it
was a really happy thing so all three of
them were sort of in my head all the way
through the writing yeah it's amazing it
never works out no it was it was so good
and she actually like looks like that
you know she's yeah I had photos
on the wall and I was like yeah I could
see
he like was so hilarious yeah because
he's so he's obviously the most handsome
man in the world and that's fine and so
his tape came in and I was like oh great
he's the handsome it's the hot Chef
remember in Paris and I didn't I have to
sit down to it with enormous excitement
and within about 10 seconds just like oh
okay and then I called him up and we
worked on it together and he's just his
love if you talk to him he said love me
guys you'll fall in love he's a lovely
guy you're hopeful romantic meet Luca's
brother yeah meet Luca's brother so um
no he's Sensational and um yeah it was
brilliant telling Julia it was him as
well